welcome to this video yeah this is a new
video about the world championship match
guarantee played in sochi russia between
Magnus Collins the defending world
champion and vc Anand yeah this is game
8 and it's a color change of course
Anand no has wide again and definitely a
game way wants to put some pressure on
the defending champion he needs to get a
win badly as he's training in the match
end with white the chants obviously
higher than with black let's see deform
again yeah probably as expected it seems
that Arnold is sticking with that have
been giving him given up on getting
anything in the Berlin so we have d4
again in cars in place again 26 so the
gruene felt in Game one was probably a
one-off and now he's some sticking to
what he usually does in six however it's
not a move that commits to something it
can lead to many openings and after
Knight f3 which to be perfectly honest
surprised me a little bit yeah not that
this is a bad move anything but it's now
the third time that Ireland has played
this and I was really expecting a switch
to Knight c3 at some point to allow the
names oh and maybe go for some some some
idea and the names oh just to get the
first move in New moving in a way at
this new move in the match and get this
in first but ok we have 93 again and
cousin plays d5 so he goes back to what
he did in game 3 which she lost Queens
gambit declined I'm he had played be six
in Game five but now goes back to the
Queens gambit yeah 93 there should be
seven Bishop f4 so Allen place the same
variation that has brought him the
victory earlier
castles III and now come some slight
surprise maybe cousin plays the move c5
this is not a surprise in terms of this
being um no no revolutionary new idea c5
is the old main line of this opening
this Bishop f4 Queens gambit declined in
recent years it was all night bd7 which
become has become more popular where
black is trying to prepare c5 in a way
and this way very often white went with
c5 himself to prevent this push so this
is how game 3 went but now Carlton is
doing ce-5 the old main line yeah and
now it goes like this d takes d5 which
is normal white them is playing that all
the time one reason is that if he's not
taking black very often will take
himself on default which leads to an
isolated Queen point position where it's
not that great have the bishop on a form
so let's say I move like this like we'll
just take and maybe take here and then
ask why this is really a good Bishop
whenever don't you want it on g 5y a
Saudi take c5 is what is the plate there
all the time d takes d5 black of course
recaptures yet here there's a big
parting of the ways white can play a
number of setups iam he can start with
Quincy to Roxy one Bishop e2 many moves
but the main move is to move a 3 yeah a
3 is a good move that has more than one
idea a key ideas that it controls the be
four square and the most important idea
of course YB form yeah one problem that
white sometimes has is that he has got
the bishop here on f4 and if black goes
with Queen 85 at some point this is a
somewhat annoying pin here this not the
bishop here the pin on the king
or let's say that the depending of the
night with the King on you want and this
is why a three is off useful if black
would play I mean just to make it very
simple there's before coming this is one
idea of a three and the other idea is
that why it very often wants to play
Queen c2 and put a rook on d1 either
just strictly one or long castles and
then a three is also very useful move as
knight c6 wounded and is often trying to
take the queen with night before we can
see this now that after 96 which was
played by cars and Quincy to was played
and if there if now a 3 wouldn't be on
the board then the move Knight before
would be a constant worry yeah an
interesting situation this is as much
the old main line of this opening and
form for ages now the most popular move
here is Queen to a five it is played in
I don't know hundreds of games and by
far the most popular move yes mentioned
black intends to get some counter play
on this diagonal one idea can be 94 for
example or even bishop before and this
is why white very often wants to break
this pin there many moves 92 for example
on rook t1 but also and this is one key
problem here long castles this move is
of course very very sharp as you can
imagine the White King would sometimes
feel not so safe here on the queenside
with just two points protecting it but
dwight will also have attacking ideas
with h 4 195 and so on this is a very
sharp position and it was kind of
interesting that here Carson in fact
gotten is surprised first he played the
move rupee 8 and avoided Queen a higher
that's a very interesting way to play
rook e8 on if you look at the database
and one of those big databases that are
also have it has about 8,000 games or
something
this position and rook e8 was only
played like 20 or 25 games so it's a
super rare move that probably never was
a big focus of anons OT Mullins
preparation however it's certainly a
move that they will have looked at at
some point and this is due to one very
simple fact if you fire up this position
here 19 and give it to a computer like
Houdini yeah you can guess what
Houdini's first choices it's rookie aid
at least if you let it like check it for
30 seconds this is what I tried and this
means that this is a move that they
certainly would have checked even if
it's a rare move but if the computer
gives it as the best move I mean we're
talking about very small differences
here like 0.32 0.2 or whatnot but the
computer is definitely considering rook
e8 as a it's a playable move so this is
some something that will probably have
caught the attention of Carson and his
team and they got in this surprise this
new move in a way first which is I think
always psychologically important and
also reason why I would have expected
let's say at some point alan to play
play into the NIMS oh and try to get
something new in first he sort of just
repeated what he had done before now
Carson gets in ism his new idea um at
first um yeah difficult now white now
has to solve this over the board what
should he do yeah there are many many
possible ideas um it looks quite obvious
maybe to play something like like long
castles but it's probably not a move
that you are so enthusiastic them to
make if you think about the situation as
as follows black now put in the new move
with rook e8 and they probably have a
have an advantage in analysis there yeah
well maybe I learnt had seen the move at
some point that they didn't really spend
hours on it probably and there
for you have to decide over the board
what is the continuation that lets me
play for something but does not risk in
to run something something super super
aggressive something super sharp and he
decided to play the move Bishop g5 which
i think is a pretty good practical
decision it looks a bit strange to move
the bishop again but it sets up this
annoying pin and asks black ok what are
you doing about this very often why does
still having this idea to play long
castles for example if black would play
something like d4 here which is not
totally totally weird then long castles
as possible in general what needs to be
said about the move rookie aid what it
does it it prepares 'if I've and deform
so if white plays um let's say totally
nothing moves like this black will get
in this year and will definitely have an
active game yeah look look how much
progress black mayor those two pushes
really activated all of this position so
white has to react to it some way and I
think Bishop g5 is a good practical
reaction however definitely it was a
good thing by Carla's team to get in
this new interesting move rook e8 not
new in terms of novelty but a new idea
or rare idea yeah I don't know sorry
cars didn't play deform he just played
the move pretty simple move Bishop e7
just breaking the pin ok not entirely
illogical what now for white should
honor and cancel long here hmm it's an
interesting try he didn't play that but
long castles would have been interesting
but again you probably don't want to run
into the preparation of your opponent's
camp and it's not so clear that long
castles is actually threatening that
much in terms of the pressure on d5 it
is even interesting here for black to
simply ignore the pressure I mean black
can't play a move like Queen a five but
there's even such a suggestion by the
computer chooses play something like
this
and prepare Roxy eight if white now
tries to win material I mean something
like this for example then black
definitely after coming Bishop e6 and
rook c8 would have very nice
compensation look at this excellent
vision yeah those kind of positions is
this is nothing that you really want to
play over the board when you have the
clear indication that it was looked at
by the opponent so on unplayed somewhat
calm a move but still a move that keeps
pressure on he played rock t 1 I mean I
just imagine what I would do if I would
would be in his shoes and I can easily
imagine myself playing that I mean I
actually play this line is wide so it's
not a totally weird idea that I could
have this on the board yeah rook t1s
certainly useful putting it opposite the
Queen yeah Queen a5 this was clear what
else here you need to get out of the
default and with those pinning ideas
like a seeking counterplay if white is
now taking on d5 black will just take
with the night and uses this pin you
know something like that is this totally
innocuous black has discounter planned
and no problems whatsoever Bishop e7
rook c8 welcome so see txt five is
nothing and white in a way runs out of
useful moves or let's say moves that are
not Bishop b3 and move like Bishop d3
view if you can you want to avoid it as
you'd like to take on c4 in one movie
black takes but you're really out of
moves now so Bishop d3 was played sorry
we should be three was played yeah black
now went age six very useful move there
was this threat on h7 at age six is good
anyway two should edge form
and d takes e4 there are little tricks
in this position it's not totally
harmless let's say Bishop f4 black has a
5-1 of a son look at this and suddenly
there's a double attack funny there are
little tricks them yeah Bishop h4 is
more natural anyway but in this case
really the only move that you can play
yeah and cards now decides to clarify
things he takes on c4 and place a six so
what black wants to do it once again in
b5 Bishop d7 and get his problem peace
the c8 Bishop developed and normally in
the Queens gambit declined if you solve
this problem bishop issue the c8 Bishop
gets into play when you do that and
you're not like losing immediately due
to some concrete thing then normally
you're out of the woods and I think this
is this is no exception this game um a
lot now played castles what he could
have tried here is to play Bishop a to
first start with this idea the idea is
to put Bishop on b1 and go all the way
to age 7 yeah setting up this idea to
take f6 and made on age 7 or let's say
almost made on age 7 this is by the way
a funny little byproduct of this rupee
aidan's that the Queen invading own age
7 is not a direct checkmate yeah Bishop
e2 was interesting just delaying
castling but it seems that there's
really nothing terrible happening yeah
let's say b5 we should be one and now
black being faced with this idea should
play g6 he cannot really avoid that yeah
something like Bishop here runs into
this kind of business or rube his
seventh first no look 27 first is even
better yeah mate mate threatened and the
bishop hangs yeah this is what white is
dreaming about but black is really just
plain g6 and preventing that it is
leading to something quite comparable
to the game and ultimately will probably
lead to nothing it is simply a case
where black is some is too solid if you
look at the structure it is a totally
symmetric of bone structure almost c and
d file open and this is only the only
factor here the only important point is
temporary peace activity and if nothing
directly is happening in the next two
three four moves then all will evaporate
to nothing now this it was possible for
honor to do that but it's not a huge
difference it's both does not lead to
much the moola castles what you played
now was answered by b5 of course Bishop
a to ya you want to go to be one that's
the only idea that there is left Bishop
d7 Bishop be one yeah and again white is
threatening to take on f6 and play rook
t7 black has to react to it and plays
root d8 yeah that's a funny situation
very often people are afraid of this
Queen wizard on age seven but if we look
at this let's just have a look we see
that this is really not dangerous and in
fact if white is deciding to play this
little check then after this he will
even be in trouble and this queen is
like hello in some warrior not not doing
anything yeah maybe after just wondering
and this is this is definitely already a
worse for Wyatt but not sure how much
was definitely this check is not doing
anything on h7 yeah note this rook e8
move and turned out to be useful yeah it
is some really a case where blacks
position is a little bit to a solid 94
was played instead of this i this is
strongly I'm 94 and cars just replied
Bishop e7 it is quite fun yeah if you
now could magically take away that you
fall night then queen age 7 a jade would
really be checkmate but where to put the
no idea on every year square you put it
like here
I mean like here on c-54 or anywhere
else it gets taken and black gets a new
square for the king so there is really
no direct way forward yeah white now had
two principal choice he could go to see
five which was played by Anand on 93
this was slightly more aggressive trial
but the problem is a little bit that if
you go on rg3 of course what wide wants
to do in once again in Queen h7 chicken
i th five year the night is a no
tackling piece black can't play g6 and
the problem here might be that a move
like h4 looks dangerous at first but if
you think of that with tricky ideas now
the thing is that black has the two
bishops and if why it is not succeeding
with this a check and that frankly
speaking does not look like that that
there is something and direct happening
then black is enjoying the Vischer pair
and is probably just better so this is a
tricky situation for honor he definitely
cannot afford to risk too much and lose
a game if he loses another game and is
down two points the match is over so
anything here needs to be considered
very carefully and he at the end decided
to play night to see five yeah okay this
now is answered by a simple reply this
has to go cakes it takes yeah and now
this position can can be just described
as equal with some precision black he
only needs to play a little bit
precisely to make sure you actually
makes the draw there's more than one way
to achieve that I mean the easiest is
probably yeah it's debatable what's
easiest but like also could have just
taken and play rook the aid there's
really not much happening um what you
did in that game was also fairly
convincing carlin played before him
after which the queens are ya traded on
the queenside is eliminated we
had to Roxy one there's really not not
much else that that white can do yeah
Roxy one now I mean we can look at look
at this but Lex night is just far too
active and there are many variations
that really kill the whole game with
bishop at 392 and stuff like that why
does not really having any material is
just get the porn just got the pong
temporarily yeah as mentioned an island
plate rook to see one group to see one
yeah now we had further trades cakes
here takes you and 97 yeah 97 intending
to play rook c8 the C file will be the
file where everything is going to be
traded and it's really a total totally
symmetrical position yeah white has a
symbolic advantage here with this
somewhat more active bishop but the key
point is that like is covering the entry
squares securely and blacks king is
getting into the plane really quickly so
we got this night traded and a couple of
more moves and here the draw was agreed
yeah this was not a very excited game
for the spectator definitely but it's an
important game for this match as it for
the second time was a game where Carson
was the better prepared prepared player
definitely because here he managed to
get in the surprise this rook e8 move
first and it in a way got the
psychological initiative in this game
Anand had to think here for for a long
time I mean not like a nun spend hours
here but it was it is good to have this
first like get this first hit in first
even if it's a little one this a little
surprised that that shows okay I have
some new ideas as well what you do have
and this is important and in the game
for before that in the Berlin it was
also cars
let the pressure out of the opening this
is very important for the matches as all
the time it looked like are not it's
much better prepared and we'll get
advantages out of the opening and this
didn't happen in those games it's very
difficult often to react to those
novelties or those new ideas when you
feel like okay the principal move might
be long castles but it's not clear and
the other side is probably much better
prepared for that so I think certainly a
successful calls and you had absolutely
no problem whatsoever with black he also
managed to play this game really quickly
and confidently so yeah a very good game
for the defending champion now after
eight games we have a leader of 534
Carlson and this means that he has to
survive only four more games to to keep
his title um yeah I know it has two
white games left and I think in the next
game I'm curious but the next white game
by Vichy I really expect him to allow
the NIMS Oh or maybe Carlton gets in
something new in even earlier will will
we would see in in three days um yeah
form Carlton's next white game it seems
that he is relying on one he fought and
yeah it would not be easy for Anand what
is he doing he had problems in the
Berlin he had this Sicilian problem
there it isn't clear so we can be been
curious about the next game which will
be played on noon Thursday Thursday the
20s yeah okay i hope you enjoyed the
coverage of this game it admittedly
wasn't very exciting game but it belongs
to those those matches definitely okay
thanks for watching